اتفاق الهجره بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وليبيا
على كف عفريت مخاطر جمه يواجهها المهاجرون
الذين تهددهم اسلحه ميليشيات تتقمص دور
خفر السواحل
المنظمه الانسانيه اذان التنكرا افراد هذه
الميليشيات في زي حفر السواحل الليبي
ووثقت حالات استخدام للذخيره الحيه ضد
قوارب لمهاجرين في اعالي البحار
الانتقادات تشير ايضا الى نقص المسؤوليه
وشفافيه بشان متلقييا من حيث ليبيا
التطورات تاتي في ما يوضع عدد كبير من
الاشخاص الذين جرع اعتراضيهم في البحر في
مراكز ليبيه تم تشبيهها بمراكز اعتقال
منظمه حقوقيه دوليه اكدت ان المهاجرين في
ليبيا يتعرضون للتعذيب كما انهم ضحايا
للعنف الجنسي والعبوديه من قبل عناصر
الميليشيه المسلحه لكن السلطه الليبيه
تنفيذ ذلك
مدافعون عن حقوق الانسان يؤكدونا ان سد
المهاجرين من مناطق البحث والانقاذ
الاوروبيه باتجاه ليبيا يعتبر بموجب قانون
الاتحاد الاوروبي غير قانوني اذا كانت
الدول الاوروبيه متواطئه انتقادات لم تقدم
الحكومه الايطاليه ردودا عن اسئله بشانها
خاصه مع صعود اليمنيه الايطاليه
مجلس اوروبا اكد من جهته ان عرقله انشطه
الانقاذ التي تقوم بها المنظمات غير
الحكوميه والفشل في تخصيص موانئ امنه
وقريبه لانزال الذين يتم انقاذهم في البحر
في هذه الحاله في ايطاليا
تكتيكات تهدف الى فتح المجاري امام عمليات
اعتراض من قبل خفر سواحل الليبي على الرغم
من الادله القاطعه على الانتهاكات الجسيمه
لحقوق الانسان بلال الوجدان العربيه